[Musique]
aujourd'hui je m'offre une petite
escapade en deux chevaux grâce à Fabrice
et Christelle je vais pouvoir découvrir
et si on est les paysages et les routes
typiques ou atypiques d'un drelois ces
deux passionnés vont m'expliquer comment
il pouponnent et bichonne l'heure de
chevaux la deuche née en 1948 cette
voiture est capricieuse mais elle va me
montrer sa puissance et sa force de
caractère
Fabrice comment ça va salut Camille
c'est une noisette la voiture là c'est
une noisette je suis en train de faire
un petit réglage au ralenti parce que il
était un peu faible mais là c'est bon
c'est fini
il faut que tu m'expliques là déjà on
est où ici et pourquoi il y a autant de
deuches
alors ce lieu on l'a appelé le préau de
chevaux on est à dire c'est là qu'on
fait nos départs de rallye quand on fait
des événements pour pour des groupes de
personnes tu as combien de de chats là
on en a sorti une quinzaine on en a 30
en tout mais alors du coup toi tu es
mécanicien à la base j'ai appris la
mécanique sur la 2 chevaux c'est là
dessus que j'ai appris la mécanique
pourquoi elle a une mécanique spécifique
là de chevaux ouais elle est simple
donc on peut vite comprendre le
fonctionnement mécanique avec une deux
chevaux c'est pas vrai tu es en train de
me faire rêver là même moi pour
apprendre il y a rien de tel plutôt
qu'un spécialiste de la 2 chevaux est-ce
que tu sais m'expliquer la magie de
cette voiture le fait qu'elle soit
basique simple basique simple et puis
aussi le fait qu'elle soit décapotable
toutes les deux chevaux berline sont
décapotables quand on roule en deux
chevaux les gens nous disent bonjour Sur
la route et tout c'est un truc de fou
mais alors cette passion pour les deux
chevaux tu la partages pas seul
Christelle comment ça va
nickel qui c'est qui embarqué l'autre
dans la passion des deux chevaux on
s'est connu il y a longtemps avec
Christelle et puis ben la vie de
partager la passion que j'avais pour la
2 chevaux j'ai vite offert une de
chevaux d'ailleurs qui est là c'est des
petits groupes
ça la séduction en 2 secondes Fabrice il
arrive pas clin d'œil était séduite mais
rentrer dans l'univers de la 2 chevaux
est-ce que ça a été compliqué ça a été
simple ça a été facile il faut juste se
laisser porter et puis bah c'est vrai
que au premier tour de roue bah c'est
rigolo ça
se dandine dans les creux les boss on
passe les chemins facilement puis bah
après il m'a passé le volant et puis bah
voilà j'ai troqué ma samba sympa contre
une de chevaux Simone quoi Joséphine
[Musique]
en voiture Simone ouais genre on me l'a
jamais faite quoi la Joséphine
franchement tu es pas originale
avant de monter dans une voiture comme
celle-ci faut toujours faire une entrée
à la Jean-Paul Belmondo le marginal s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
merci j'ai toujours rêvé de faire ça
toujours noisette n'a que pour noisette
et Betty Boop
[Musique]
voilà et on arrive au château de mon
coupon
[Musique]
tu as vu le temps
à la maison avec les autres elles
doivent bien se de nous là
caprice